the making of a movie for me personally
always eclipses the movie itself because
it's an exploration it's an adventure
it's a hopefully a transformation The
Life Aquatic with Steve Zissou I'm Wes
Anderson because I wanted to meet him
and we just made a meeting through
friends or agents or something like that
he came to a performance at the Wooster
group of theatres that I was working at
and we went out afterwards and we liked
each other enormous ly and he was like
God it would be so great to work with
you but I'll tell you what I'm just
getting ready to shoot a movi I'm going
off to Rome to it and to Italy to shoot
this movie and it's all cast but you
know when I finish it maybe in three or
four years we can do something and I
thought happened great and then about
three or four months later he called up
and he said you know that movie I was
talking about and basically someone
dropped out I do but I'm not telling you
it's not nice to him in fact
he dropped out I think for a paycheck
and also for a movie that wasn't so
successful it was a fun character I mean
it basically for people that haven't
seen it I mean he's a blowhard German
you know if we think of Germans being
very efficient and confident and strong
and he had all that but it wasn't true
and he knew it
[Music]
there's something beautiful about that
that kind of character not only is Wes
of pure pleasure to work with
not because he's clear he's got a
beautiful energy and and he creates a
sense of community and the world that he
creates is very specific but also in
this case the role wasn't completely on
the page he was always making these
pieces and folding parts of the ensemble
into these shots these very complex
shots The Life Aquatic is filled with
these really complicated choreographed
masters that are very beautiful and that
was great fun to do and it kind of
working back to you no not back I mean
it's still working the theater but it
was like theater work a little bit we'd
work all day to get these very
complicated shots and then we pull the
trigger and do it you know and by the
end of the day you'd have a whole scene
so it was just it was a movie that as
price precise as he is it developed as
we were doing it he'd have a shot and
he'd say well why don't you go in there
and so there was stuff invented on the
spot
even with his wildly well-prepared very
clear very detail-oriented way of
working
don't marry Bill Murray he's uh I won't
say a force of nature he is a force of
nature he's hard to pin down and he's so
much fun to be with and he's a very
generous soul when you work with them he
there's nothing predictable about him
and he works with a lot of love and
that's mixed with a little perversity a
little natural perversity there's
nothing every strained about bill he's a
very fluid person and performer
the spider-man was fun Sam Raimi did a
miracle thing he made kind of a personal
film out of a you know fairly big size
partly effect movie it was before it was
early in the game of you know movies
from from comic books and that sort of
thing so there was no there was no
template I loved in spider-man
particular playing the double role
everybody thinks about the Green Goblin
and that was fun but the more
interesting role was probably the father
because Norman Osborn because you could
play these scenes where it would switch
from comedy to drama in a line I think
of the scene where they have like a
Thanksgiving dinner Norman will you do
the honors
there's a couple of things that still
make me laugh because they're so
double-edged and they go back and forth
between being really heavy and really
kind of silly and the movie is filled
with that the Mears in school sam raimi
gave me dr. Jekyll and mr. Hyde to read
before that but it was fun and we we
basically did it in one take I think in
the final thing for whatever reason they
cut it but I we always shot it in one
take and it became a beautiful gang
because I had to switch those things and
also for the camera to be in the mirror
the correct way and I had to dance with
the camera a lot on that scene there are
a lot of mechanical effects in that
because I think some of the visual
effects weren't so sophisticated then
and they were really fun to do to be on
a Y or to fly around
that's fun it's it's athletic and it's
challenging and it's yeah cops and
robbers it's fun
Florida Browns fan motor project was a
beautiful project because for many
reasons Shaun Baker is a really strong
good principled filmmaker and it was a
beautiful opportunity
I've always loved movies where you can't
tell who the performers are and who the
found people are when they mix
professional actors with people in fact
I'm very much attracted to films where
the actors are not don't feel like
actors even when actors give
performances that don't feel performed I
like that so here was an opportunity to
not be an actor I mean sometimes they're
very showy performances that's very as
surfacing performance sometimes there's
very performed performances and part of
the pleasure is the spectacle of it and
that that craft of it but normally
soulfully I like movies where I don't
feel like an actor and this was a
perfect opportunity for that because
Shaun created an environment where we
were mixing with the people of a real
place and they were kind of guiding us
on how to make the movie because it was
really about their experience of course
there was the structure of course there
was a fiction of course there was a
screenplay it wasn't all improvised and
it wasn't just about you know having
kids or or untrained actors or
first-time actors it wasn't just about
that it was I wanted to be a manager of
a hotel motel and I was and I learned
how to do that and it's supported what
I've always thought about performing the
important thing is as an actor you do
things you don't show you do and I loved
also that movie because of what it
expressed it
press star you know how important it is
to take care of each other and what what
social responsibility we need to have
for each other
eternities gate directed by Julian
Schnabel a film about made by a painter
about a painter I play the Vincent van
Gogh it was written by Julian and
jean-claude carrière yeah it's a not a
traditional biopic when he was writing
the script he asked he sent me some
material sent me some biographical
material and told me to take notes of
the things that I was interested in and
some of that stuff was incorporated into
the script so even though I wasn't
involved in the script right and I felt
a part of it and then he never really
asked me to do the part I did that just
as a friend and just for my own pleasure
and then one day he invited me over to
his house and they put a ridiculous red
beard on me and posed me and took some
pictures and then it was shortly after
that that he said let's do this thing
and I never asked him what that was
about maybe it was to show to infestors
I don't know why I didn't even want to
ask tell me why do say to a painter I
guess I loved painting I have to paint
I've always been a painter that I know
one of the nice things about playing
characters based on darkness that are
real-life characters based characters
based on historical characters is
there's usually a wealth of material you
have a wealth of things to study and it
changes how you think
I mean I've played the ones that come to
mind of course Jesus a lot is written
about him TS Eliot with Van Gogh you
have the paintings you have the letters
it's a wealth of things to research but
then of course ultimately you have to
forget the research and you have to
forget that you're playing Vincent van
Gogh or or Jesus and try to find the
human aspect
that's when that Saints was a movie by
Troy Duffy that became something of a
cult hit pretty much pretty much all
over the world but it was a movie that
never really had a proper release it
started with if you don't know the story
Troy Duffy was working in a bar that had
a lot of Industry people in it and he
also really loved movies and he
basically I had an idea for a movie and
he rode it and then he passed it to one
of his clients and they went crazy for
the script and there was a big bidding
war which Harvey Weinstein then won and
he was going to make this movie and part
of his strategy to get this movie done
was he started to do a lot of press
about how he had found the next
Tarantino or something like that there
was a big hubbub about this movie before
the guy even shot of foot but then they
started to have arguments about the
casting is my understanding and it was
put in turn around then a company have
picked it up and in that in that version
then I was cast as this character
smacker who was a very interesting
character he's a very intuitive
detective he's he's gay but he he has a
special connection to classical music
there's many things that are interesting
about him it's basically a comic
performance mixed with action stuff and
fun kind of politically incorrect things
I think that's why it has a big
following there's a you know I can tell
up when the certain person comes up to
me I know what movie they kind of talk
about it's that kind of movie
click tone was very important for me
because not only is was it a movie that
I liked very much and I love the
experience of doing it but it also
changed a lot of things in the sense
that it was one of the first movies that
was both a critical and popular success
and it was my first Oscar nomination
also it's it kind of crossed over into
hard-nose a little bit because I think
it did have an effect on Vietnam vets
how they were accepted and how they were
viewed so it had a really positive
social effect I don't want to
overestimate that but as part of the
movie I felt that very much
it's better to get into the first few
things also the preparation was really
intense and wonderful and a little
irresponsible you probably couldn't do
that now it's been much imitated since
that this idea that you get some people
and you get material military people to
train them what we did was really pure I
think we got thrown out in the jungle we
didn't know what was going to happen we
heard something vague about two weeks
training the stuff the people that
brought us out of the jungle basically
left us there it was like we were
stranded and manifestly ok your agents
aren't here you don't make phone calls
you don't do anything dig in and we
started dig holes and we made a
perimeter and we played war and it
sounds maybe silly but the people that
were training us were very sincere and
very serious about this and they wanted
to teach us how to do soldierly things
and I think that was very important
because it rooted the movie we can never
know what that experience is but what we
could do is we could learn how to do
these soldier things and then apply
ourselves in the context of the scenario
and then things would happen to you and
it would be with the little imagination
it would become a bonafide experience so
I think that was partly the heart of the
movie and also the fact that it was a
personal story from Oliver that ran
really deep and also some of the people
that were helping to train us had a
personal stake in it I was like 31 years
old 30 years old something like that I
was like an old timer most of the people
you look at that cast now a lot of those
people that was their first film not
only in their first film but some of
these guys had never been out of the
country with Johnny we had a beautiful
scene that was caught Axl but I could
tell even as we were shooting it Oliver
didn't think it was working but I loved
it very much because we were we were out
there and he was telling me about his
girl
from back home and it was very sweet
scene and we're doing all of this
cleaning ourselves on the field as these
helicopters are flying over our heads
like really close so the idea of all
that flesh and all this kind of intimate
stuff among us and physically next to
all this Hardware going over our head
really express something that I thought
was interesting Antichrist it was one of
my favorite experiences in film i I
think Lars von Trier is really you know
his films aren't for everyone but I
think he's a very gifted and brave
filmmaker he's not maybe the easiest guy
I think he's got a nose to go towards
taboo subjects not because as many
people think he's a just transgressive
or or enfant reap it's really the stuff
that interests him and he's got a gift
for film language I think the the
prologue of Antichrist
[Music]
and the epilogue
[Music]
are just gorgeous that that's worth the
price of admission as they say and then
the rest of the movie of course is
difficult
of course it's ultra violent in in
places but I think it it explores some
really interesting things about
motherhood about sexuality about guilt
about mourning about mental illness
about myths about certain things about
women's power men's fear of women very
delicate subjects I think it really hits
them head-on
some of my favorite films are films that
express sort of the making of them and
Antichrist was one of those that it
looked like it felt I do watch my films
I've been in at least once so because
I'm curious about how they turned out
but generally I don't linger I mean you
know really when I see a movie it's not
gonna really I don't like to think about
studying it or learning from it I think
you learn and the doing I enjoy movies
but when it's my own it becomes too
egocentric to really study it or look at
it too much one of the beautiful things
was that was a film where I worked from
imitation and imitation has its
limitations but it's also a beautiful
way to work because it frees you and I
worked with a mask a literal mask and
metaphorical mask you know and that's
that also frees you so I felt very free
to goof around to have fun to be
perverse and to be this you know
otherworldly character the basic conceit
the basic idea behind the film that you
know this director
now is going to use a real vampire you
know in the movie about a vampire is
kind of a a joke and seems kind of
vassal er simple but the way plays out
was pretty interesting and you can mix
elements of real horror and comedy which
is tricky but for me it was a drink
because I had this heavy mask
I had a great model in the original of
Nosferatu
so the movement and how to look and how
to act I could copy start from there and
then once you're copying it freeze a
certain energy that you would normally
imagine you'd you'd use on invention to
play around I don't know I just felt
very free I felt like I wasn't there it
played into a kind of boyish sense of
play and invention achilles cage was a
producer on it and originally I think
this was something he developed for
himself it was created by his company or
developed by his company and I think
originally he was going to play
Nosferatu and I don't know whether he
got busy or the project was too small or
for whatever reason he started looking
for other casting I think he cast
already John Malkovich as mur knob and
he didn't know who he was going to cast
for the vampire in the cast me and I
remember right before we were ready to
start Nick came in and we did a table
reading and he's a very inventive guy
I've worked with him on wild at heart
and also on doggy-dog Paul Schrader
movie and I liked him a great deal and
he's fun to work with but at this table
reading afterwards he had lots of ideas
and we're going to shoot the next day
and he had some ideas about how he
wanted the the vampire character to be a
movie fan he thought that was
interesting and for me I thought that
ruined the whole idea so I kind of
argued with him and went back to the
hotel room if I'm gonna get fired I just
haven't had a serious argument and maybe
when I get attached to something maybe
I'm not always polite you know I had a
serious argument with him about this
idea who knows whether the idea would
stay he's a pretty impulsive guy but he
was gone the next day and we proceeded
as normal and I enjoy the movie
David Lynch was one of the most fun
people to work with and it was partly
because he was so clear he gave me a
beautiful setup people imagine sometimes
that you know a good actors director is
someone that talks to you and pulls you
aside and tells you how to do things
that hasn't been my experience my
experiences they create a world or they
create a setup or invite you to
collaborate in such a way that there's a
logic to what you're doing you're clear
and the beautiful things happen in your
presence or your commitment you're
experiencing the things that are
happening the best experiences are
always when you get a good set up and
David Lynch gave me such a good set up
and really didn't give me any choices
like in terms of costume he he basically
brought this thing out on a hanger and
said Willem this is your costume and I
was good with that normally you'd have a
conversation with that this is what I
think this is what you think my bump up
but it was very direct and I responded
immediately to it and then he said we
gotta sent you to the dentist
and I said why and I read the script
thing I know that he had stumpy
discolored teeth but I made the
assumption that we just do it with
makeup he said no no we gotta we gotta
make you some dentures and I thought
wild so we had these dentures made
and they were the key to the character
sir
dummies I got those teeth and it kept my
mouth open like this in a way that you
know I was able to tap into a kind of
lasciviousness you know you go like this
you know and all of a sudden you start
sitting differently no you start feeling
differently that became the King it
shows that actors sometimes left to
their own devices put limitations on
themselves I would never thought of that
strangely enough I just assumed
something
it wasn't studied it was kind of
intuitive but I think Bobby Peru is one
of my most complete character sessions
The Last Temptation of Christ
I played Jesus Christ in the last
temptation of Christ it demanded a lot
of me and when I was finished with the
film I felt finished and that's a
wonderful feeling you felt used you felt
like you you directed some energy and in
a way and you couldn't do any more
Martin Scorsese had made this movie in
his head ever since Barbara Hershey gave
him the book Last Temptation he knew
it's so well he tried to make it before
this was like the second time he tried
to do it it was a very low-budget movie
when I get a call from my agent saying
Martin Scorsese wants to talk to you I
was like for what he said last
temptation of Christ I was like for what
role he said stupid for Christ I thought
that's weird and then I read the script
and I said ah
this is beautiful and I met with him in
the most direct way went into New York
because I was someplace else at the time
and we had a short conversation and I
said okay let's do this thing
how I entered into that was quite simple
and quite surprising and it was very
clear that you know the emphasis was to
find the human aspect of Jesus and the
first thing that I had to do is forget I
was playing Jesus
and to cleanse myself of some kinds of
expectations maybe this relates to what
I said before about you know a
performance that doesn't feel acted I
had to find how this very historic
character how he was a human being you
know can't you see what's inside of me
we all sin not my sense I'm a liar a
hypocrite I'm afraid of everything
I don't ever tell the truth I don't know
the courage and of course the script and
the whole everything supports that but
it was a beautiful beautiful experience
we shot in Morocco no trailers
down-and-dirty she'd shot fast so that
we never got you know seduced into any
big pageantry or got distracted
it was so essential in fact one of the
few things that he had me research
he didn't gave me two things at my
archaeological study about crucifixion
an article about forgiveness
of course I on my own I was reading the
Bible a lot then and told me to watch
pass Cellini's Gospel according to
Matthew he said this is more the
direction we want to go something
essential something human something
understandable unless temptation I
wasn't at all prepared for controversy
because I thought it was a beautiful
film I was leaving my house during the
height of the controversy and there was
a guy sitting on the stoop and I was
walking out and he said hey man you you
made that Jesus movie right and I said
yeah and he said yeah a hell of a lot of
trouble about that Hey and I said well
yeah and he said that's what you do when
you change the story
which I thought was a curious thing
Mississippi Burning Alan Parker asked to
see me I read a script I thought it was
a great story I thought that I really
liked Alan Parker
I knew Gene Hackman was going to be in
it and I thought oh to perform to play
the straight man to a colorful great
character for a gene Hackman how
beautiful is that I can confess right
now that initially on paper my character
seemed blue flat low colorless in the
doing of it it became less and less
colorless it became a very beautiful
character and the shooting was so much
fun and even though the the story is
very heavy and involves a lot of tragedy
and injustice and very dark themes
I got a same shooting it was a lot of
fun you know because it was a
combination of a really good cast
something rooted in history but also
partly invented Alan Parker was just a
lot of fun to work with for an actor and
Hackman was great you know it just to be
with him was great I remember we were
ready to finish and I had a couple more
days to work and Gene Hackman said he
said let's go out for dinner and say
goodbye I wasn't close with him I mean
we were good he was very kind to me on
the set and I liked working with him a
great deal was very happy to work with
him and we had a little dinner and at
the end he said listen I've enjoyed
working with you this might be a good
movie and listen you've got a couple of
days left
you might want to see if you can find
some other colors
I thought was pretty good I'd say Jean
I'm the straight man to you you're the
color guy the Lovelace Lovelace was
basically my first film
uh it was Kathryn Bigelow's first
feature
it was co-directed with a guy by the
name of Monty Montgomery who was a
producer for David Lynch so that's where
I met Kathryn and we had a wonderful
time making that movie haven't worked
with Kathryn since but that was really a
good experience it was a motorcycle
movie we're going nowhere fast they were
free spirit I had never ridden a
motorcycle and there I am in New York
City I'm working at the theater I don't
have an agent
Kathryn sees me in a theater piece at
the Wooster group in downtown in New
York and they call me up and say we want
to send your script
we want you to be the lead in this movie
and I read it and I say great yeah and I
want to do it but I don't know what to
ask for anything I I'm not part of the
the movie world right and then they talk
about I don't want to lose the parts so
that say have you ridden a motorcycle
of course classically what is the mat to
do they lie I say yeah I have you know I
haven't ridden in a while but you know
and so they say I get this part and they
say okay we're gonna go out to
Connecticut to ride on this you know
1955 big Harley hog you know and I think
oh my god what am I gonna do I don't
know how to ride a motorcycle
so I start asking around if anyone has a
motorcycle I'm a young kid in in New
York City
I don't know anybody with a motorcycle
much less a 1955 pan have you know a big
machine and that's before the Internet
so I'm going to the library to get a
book on how to shift you know is it one
down two up you know I'm like I'm
wrapping it around
head so we go out there I still haven't
confessed it I haven't you know ridden a
motorcycle and I get on that machine and
it takes off with me I go riding you
know it takes up with me I go you know
through backyards of some fancy
neighborhood in Connecticut where this
impeccably lovably restored 1955 Harley
Davidson you know it was housed so I
think they figured that out pretty quick
but they were patient with me and then
learn to ride mr. Bean's Holiday I mean
it was strange choice for me to do I was
happy to do it and it was fun to do I
think one of the reasons I want to do it
is I always remember Rowan Atkinson not
so much from mr. bean but but from
Blackadder and when I saw Blackadder I
just thought this guy's fantastic the
highly artistic but also highly illegal
set of French lithographs everything
using clock where the little man comes
out and drops his trousers every half
hour
I was really sucked into what he was
doing so the idea to work with him was
great fun and then also the character I
play once again kind of a blowhard
what's the pattern here huh was a very
full of himself art filmmaker
the guy with the video camera is fired
ah so that's some money know a little
something about one of the things that
we did that was really crazy is one of
the scenes happens at the Cannes Film
Festival
so we stole the red carpet and kN
I think we had permission but I'm not
sure we on the red carpet of a
Portuguese filmmaker named Pedro Costa
who is seen whose films are very serious
from very strong we invaded his red
carpet I felt guilty i morally thought
it was the wrong thing to do but we did
it anyway so that was fun to live in
down in the lake Billy Friedkin really
fun to work with good script interesting
character I'm driving around in a
Ferrari I've got a beautiful house I'm
also getting to learn how to print money
that was really fun and really
fascinating that's one movie that I've
looked back at and I thought you look
like a little kid you know but you're
playing such a heavy character and I
remember when I was in New York when I
was younger and I'd be going out to
clubs sometimes these real imposing guys
would say oh it's Rick masters you know
somehow it worked you know that that
character was like had some you know was
scary was made people nervous yeah I do
but you know it used to be there used to
be a fear that I'd get caught you know
do it again do it again do it again
and that deadens you it's not just a
pride of an actor saying I can do other
things
it just isn't interesting if you go to
the same well you're not you're not
nourishing yourself bad guys are fun
because they can do things that we can't
do in life you know you can you can play
around with their your dark side and we
all have it I enjoy that but I was
always conscious of type guy
and thankfully as I get older it gets
pretty mixed up but at the beginning of
my career people started saying this guy
plays bad guys and and I was worried
about that I'm not so much anymore maybe
I should be or maybe I haven't played
good bad gaming well maybe I'm do okay
you ride for me
[Music]